we haven't answered every question about
what actually happened on January 6 far
from it there's so many mysteries from
that day but one thing we know for
certain is that the story they told you
about it a pat tale of good versus evil
an Insurrection with no guns that took
place at the U.S Capitol those were lies
and they were lies told for a very
specific purpose of course the people in
power wanted more power and they got it
on the basis of those lies
but in the process many lives were
destroyed and some people are still in
jail tonight not having had their
constitutionally guaranteed moment in
front of a jury of their peers they
haven't even put on trial yet and
they're still rotting
Julie Kelly is the one journalist in
this country who's been following us
very closely she wrote a book on it
January 6th how Democrats use the
capital protest to launch a war on
terror against the political right which
is a perfect summation of what actually
happened Julie Kelly joins us now Julie
thanks so much for coming on
um so at dawn.s as these tapes made very
clear that the story we've been
presented is is an absolute fabrication
it's a lie it's a fraud that
people may still be in jail on the basis
of these lies and so we wanted to talk
to you for an update on where those
cases are tonight
so yes there are well at least a hundred
men have been held under pre-trial
detention orders over the past two years
that means that a judge has denied them
bail because the government doj
successfully argued that that individual
was a threat to the community this
includes Tucker people charged with
non-violent offenses like obstruction
and conspiracy so of course they don't
have access to what could very easily be
exculpatory evidence contained in this
video but aside from the now I think
around three dozen men who are held
under pre-trial detention orders Tucker
Believe It or Not There are some men
going on 24 25 26 months denied bail
languishing in jail including the DC
Gulag as the government continues to
delay their trials this all has the
imprimatur by the way of every judge on
the D.C District Court I want to
emphasize the real villains here year
are the federal judges in Washington D.C
who have allowed the government to play
every single game to keep this evidence
out of the hands of defendants violating
their oath of office to protect the
rights of defendants and their due
process rights so I really want to
emphasize that but look Tucker there's a
thousand criminal defendants right now
half of them have pleaded guilty or been
convicted at trial so and the government
just announced in two months ago in
January that they were still uploading
Global they called discovery which means
material related to the entire
investigation what they did was arrest
people first find the evidence later and
cover up what could potentially
exonerate these defendants
If This Were happening in any other
country the U.S state Department would
immediately acknowledge that these were
violations of the most basic human
rights these are political prisoners and
the US government would condemn it but
it's happening here and it's ignored
except by you and I so appreciate your
tireless reporting on this Julie Kelly
thank you
thank you Tucker
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight